walk him to this video he's ok 44 from
from China let's go for the bull go
let's go for the Bogle yeah check this
is some one of the lines I have in my
book and i also have fun plateless
successfully over the board leads to a
very solid play like him managed to
exchange his bishop and after that put
everything on dark squares that's a
modest approach but not a bad one let's
see how to how to develop hmm yeah okay
I am yeah I know this is a bit uncommon
because it weakens d5 I mean I come and
not like uncommon theoretical move but
the setup but d5 is not a square that
you can use at the moment and there was
a bit afraid of Bishop to b4 these kind
of ideas
like to play b6 Bishop e7 I wonder about
night h4 night h4 f5 this might be a
good idea light edge for
v I don't know if you place any slow
stuff I don't think I'm in any trouble
maybe you can play some claim something
due to the bishops but it shouldn't be
shouldn't be serious nigeria move
intending bishop d5 or i can just play
age six well relief how much time is he
taking here I hope it's not disconnected
no okay what should I go h 6 mm yeah
normally it's not it's not bad to have
nights exchanged in those positions the
bishops are not not so powerful ok so
it's maybe going for night h 4f five
after all but only after weakening my
structure a bit yeah and where there was
not much I could do about it but it's
probably not not fatal ok however what
do I play now nitey for others Rock g7
unfortunately
okay 96 rookie 695 may be okay but on 96
I shop okay yeah I'd like to get night
the night 26 this would be nice to e6
and 2d for this would solve all my
problems
okay but on night oh hmm that's a very
aggressive move mmm I didn't writer not
bad probably okay can I ever take bishop
a6 this looks really bad
okay it takes Knight takes Knight h6 if
i move the noid is probably playing e6
next yeah I probably need to do that
anyway and I have some camel toe chances
i mean probably this is very really bad
but he's his yeah I am but I thought I
can maybe give give up the exchange for
some compensation here and there's also
93 I that's also 93 i get i get i get 93
in so i get get the exchange bag
query for probably there's some better
better move okay night takes me that's a
simple move maybe maybe i can i can just
put it only six and try to kill this
bishop maybe maybe it's too ambitious
but ok this is all protected now try to
open up the position i'd get to his skin
twin h1 ok Ruth German that wasn't so
great ok this wasn't wasn't good at all
this idea it's it's still very tricky
and now I'm now I'm not fine even I came
but how how exactly would be a tricky
one I'm back again
hmm I can also take you five of course
maybe let's just get the pawn
oops I didn't see that one Chang it's
nothing nothing terrible but I gave away
some of my I think I was better even but
I gave some to give up some some of that
check time morning so check check
check check draw one forfeits on time
yeah I offered it so lady couldn't
really accept it yeah I should have
offered to Talia really but it's hard to
to really see what what exactly is going
on on the clock yeah I mean around here
we both gave good positions away here
I'm really in good shape tween a5 check
is strong and this also didn't look too
bad again Queen f5 check is good go now
this is this was a bad one and a bad
move to take the pawn this is much
better check yeah check one important
point so we need to do something like
that and this is not this is simply not
nice they are blacks winning here they
are very very tough game it looked
really critical and here I'm i don't
know i probably should just take a look
defined f6 ma I saw that but I thought
it would be interesting to try to get
the night here and keep this Bishop bad
but he still has the d file so it's
probably not a valid idea this idea to
play with mp5 is active but weakens he
only needs to avoid queen of three and
play maybe that one yeah fighting game
okay thanks for watching